hi again I'm Linda and today we're gonna
work on a pasta installation that has
tons of different interesting shapes of
pasta and we're gonna have so much fun
with the possibilities we are going to
build out an art piece that will have a
core a heart and that core in the middle
will be made of a raviolo nay raviolo
nay just means big raviolo - that's our
center that is the center of our
universe right there number two is going
to be a bunch of square ravioli with all
of this pasta when we're done today we
are going to boil it all we're gonna eat
all of these different colors sometimes
there are just pasta scraps that have
become too dry a couple of uses for them
you can actually bake them turn them
into crackers use them to scoop up a
cheese or a dip that you've made
I feel like pasta and pasta making for
me is just this Zen
ARF it's very meditative we will have
triangle ravioli around the squares
those will be orange they're really
funky and pretty you can't forget the
farfalle farfalle is like the classic
shape the look of butterflies when I was
making pasta and I was a little kid I
could barely hold a knife and we didn't
have any fancy tools for pasta making so
farfalle I would say was a really
approachable easy one to start just
because that one is such a classic and
once you learn to really make it you can
make a thousand of them this is my
friend the pasta bike nice to meet you
next up is a shape called pakery hackery
are rolled on a dowel it's a good thing
that we're all adults here because it's
gonna remind you of something else but
get your mind out of the gutter and
truly just enjoy the artistry of the
process but I think you can really
appreciate and enjoy it on many levels
next up we have cooler Gianna's cooler
geo nazar from Sardinia little island
off of Italy it's these little washy
chubby little dumplings that are rolled
and shaped in a very interesting and
unique way so right now I'm actually
really into pasta origami I'm getting a
lot of inspiration from other sort of
art forms and how I can bring that to my
pasta so for me these shapes are so cool
and I love being able to show people
some of the classics that we've made
today
we have in Ghana preppy in Ghana preppy
means trick the priest the story behind
that and the trick is that they look
like they're a little tortellini but
there's nothing inside surprise we have
is really cool just with beef strands of
fettuccine our strands are again all of
the colors represented it actually looks
really pretty already imagine what its
gonna look like I always thought my
entire life that I was an artist and
everybody always told me that I wasn't
that I was terrible well it turns out
that I just hadn't found my medium I get
really inspired by the entire world
around me when I'm making pasta I feel
like when you sort of have found your
medium you're just always looking for
ways to express it and I do think to me
brings a little bit of a deeper sense of
soul to my work pasta la vista baby oh
yes
[Music]
[Music]